welcome to Churchville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by my bookie new holiday cash you need
it and I know where to get it
my bookie is the place to score some
serious cash and your sports predictions
believe it or not the holiday is around
around the corner and while that means
plenty of parties gifts and spending it
also means there's a lot of football
basketball hockey bowl games college
basketball and you could score big every
day there's nothing like waking up in
the morning blasting the betting and
getting paid like a doctor so what is
what I'm telling you go to my bookie
join now and they'll match a deposit
with up to a 50% bonus you heard that
right
a 50% bonus use promo code Church to
activate the offer visit my bookie AG
and use promo code Church you play you
win and you get paid like a [ __ ]
now for my other people if you're an
honor customer you know it's that time
of the year you ration your mCP or
outgrown you a heartbeat kettlebell and
you're down to your last alpha brain
listen what I'm gonna do this Friday the
24th at midnight Anna is turning on the
Black Friday sale to 1125 percentile
supplements including alpha brain 30%
off apparel and gear holy [ __ ] head to
audit dot-com Black Friday and sign up
for alerts to be one of the first to
know in the first two shop that's gonna
calm Black Friday that take advantage of
the biggest deals and it's also the time
of the year where you fat [ __ ] want to
get in shape you want to join jujitsu
here you go go to 4G supports calm and
get yourself a nice a five or a six
get yourself four separate oh and guess
what put in church and I'm gonna give
you a 10% off it's that [ __ ] easy
take that mother [ __ ] meal Lee are you
[ __ ] kidding me or what
that's Rick James sling and dick and
banging white chicks three at a time up
in Buffalo you know I'm saying he'd made
the temptations watch they were too old
there's no viagra
be real in the [ __ ] house he
met he made the temptation sang can you
believe they just sing [ __ ] I'm
gonna [ __ ] these white old [ __ ] and do a
lot of coke could you imagine if he was
alive how many accusations we've been
coming up yeah he would've been in a
Cell right next to Harvey it seems
that's happening with you know like
people like bigwigs right now you know
they haven't got like so many of the the
artists that aren't as like poppin as
the ones they've been going after like
you know Kevin Spacey that's like a mega
superstar actor when you think about it
but yeah that look like in his face that
he was sucking like right like he was
sucking like 18 year-old dicks this is
like 25 yeah yeah I guess you could say
that yeah that little confidence level a
little [ __ ] uh what's that [ __ ] that
white people have when they get that
white privilege privilege whatever I
suck young big entitlement really is
that walk around I only suck
sixteen-year-old dick he's it and he's
entitled to that's right I don't I don't
talk to 24 year old that milk is tart I
sucked that sweet milk like cereal milk
[Laughter]
that's filthy [ __ ] [ __ ] Secret Garden
the diva the guy that cracks me the most
is the Democrat the dude that's running
from limitation that yeah yeah dude
Alabama you know I love you like a
brother right right in like my eyes when
I moved to Boulder in 85 I had $10,000
at 18 I just settled so suit some guy
put telling the bank and I walked around
with a like Johnny Bananas I went
through in a month right cuz that's what
we do we ranked we're in a month and
pizza slices who eats eight thousand
dollar slices it's a lot of pizza and
nickel bags so I had to get a job so I
went through this mall with a fake
credit card and I mean I banged
everybody out but didn't when I was
robbing the [ __ ] mall I applied for a
job then I got the job well I think of
me a ma
I robbed every place in there never got
banned from the mall this [ __ ]
was hitting on so many 16-year old
chicks they banned him from the more and
wait till they start getting their
reports in the roller skating rink
yeah see he killed all those [ __ ] cuz
I know that
[ __ ] was rollerskating on Sundays too
[ __ ] Elton John songs and that's
crazy because one of the law enforcement
around there
you know said yeah you know he's that
he's known he's known to talk to
underage girls blah blah blah it's a
common it's common knowledge and you
know that's that's law enforcement
saying that about your ass you know when
you're running for office down there
you'd almost crazy when I was 18 and I
hated talking to him their age girls
when I was 16 I hated talking to 16 year
old girls do you know that like I like
older women
I always liked talking to a little older
even a couple years at that age makes a
big difference it does like that's why
when I see guys at a 50-day the 22 year
old [ __ ] you'd be talking about
whistles yeah yeah what do you gotta get
what do you got it kosis what do you
have in common after you [ __ ] him 20
times and you settle millpond him and
yeah and then a poor girl that's 20
she's blown a kid in high school his
milk tastes like gonna Kevin Spacey's
nephews and then she decides to suck a
dick as old and ratty is mine and that's
like skim milk with [ __ ] goat cheese
in it and [ __ ] vomit new chunks what
do you do do you stick around and take
that abuse you know I would imagine
depending on the pocketbook you know
some stick around but if it's broke
[ __ ] they're out boom out of
here good to have you on the show could
the good be walk-in never in my life
have I met somebody who's been in more
bands you're the man trade profits of
fire and water Ricans are the knife to
Mexicans in a beanie no know that bingo
throw your air there being God no no man
that's a bit credit because that means
you haven't stopped since God knows one
that this all start well you know um our
first Cypress Hill album came out in 91
but you know we like you know just as
enthusiasts as as this [ __ ] was our
hobby this is the [ __ ] we love Run DMC
was like you know the first [ __ ] did
turned me on to hip hop really I mean
there was stuff out before and Run DMC
and we learned about that
but that was the [ __ ] and you know just
doing it like emulating those guys we
were doing it probably like an 85 86 but
you know we turned pro by getting a deal
in in 1990 in releasing the album in 91
and from there you know we just kind of
you know we we were thankful for having
the [ __ ] opportunity because you know
we didn't know if our [ __ ] was gonna hit
or not we knew we had some different
[ __ ] that was kind of hard to swallow
you know I'm saying like you know like a
brand new porn chick trying to you know
suck off what's his name
no yeah yeah or the elephant [ __ ]
Jeremy dude very cool dude know what I'm
saying you know that [ __ ] is tough when
you first see Jeremy what's his name Ron
Jeremy you first see Ron Jeremy you
freeze you freeze up you take a Rock
Hudson you think of skinny people you
should yeah you know how all those holes
he busted their ass holes and you're
kind of hesitant to shake his hand yeah
and why are you shaking his hand you're
like they better be Purell in the back
yeah or you better have some gloves on
talk to me in a bank lot one time like I
don't know is it cool dude what the [ __ ]
am I this is 15 years of my go ahead man
you're a bad [ __ ] they stopped
we talked you think about it he's a
legend in his field he really is know
him so do you know like again our music
I can't wait till somebody says he
sexually harassed him huh that's gonna
be the best he's like ba ba
I had a mall [ __ ] sue me I sexually
harassed him on tape and got paid for it
yeah crazy no no no it's a different
world we live in
oh yeah I might even put my a my arms
around women no more when I take head
shots
I decided shoulder the shoulder like the
Marines don't say [ __ ] yeah that did
yeah because you never know I know
something you got sued for headlock and
people you know like when that's your
see fighters in a headlock them to UFC
fight that's why they're not allowed to
headlock you no more big
is or strangle you [ __ ] hey man I just
asked for a picture and now I got this
broken [ __ ] neck but you know what's
crazy to me that I've been thinking I'm
54 Mulder like everybody says rap
started with let's pretend I don't even
know let's just pretend I'm talking
online here the Sugar Hill Gang right
let's put that you know well they were
like I think the first to one of the
first to put out a big record I saw
something the other day that blew my
mind I'm gonna show you guys real quick
I want you to put on the finally All
Stars live from Japan won't that doodle
ok this like this is what I was thinking
about like how okay let's take what's
the what's the the form of music that
first started in 83 out of the boxes
they used to put boxes out and do the
wars and [ __ ] yeah that was based off of
you know the DJ's like Kool Herc and
grab masterful as a doing there were
Wars yeah you know what's been on my
head just spin around yeah and I would
get up and instead of fist fight like
floor it was like they were dancing they
were playing right there yes they're
playing brakes well the the guys were
breakdancing you know b-boying b-boying
all that like right now that one of the
best jujitsu schools is the ones with
the one the dudes where they would break
dancers yeah well they have a
breakdancing school those two jujitsu
schools which a 10th planet those
[ __ ] are killing be healing
because their bodies what's the name of
the song I have live in Japan Pete all
NTD you are oh this is one of the
weirdest things I just when I write at
night I put YouTube on and I put the
music on one I don't really hear the
music but I just there and you're
writing and my typing and you're doing
this it's ambience and it's something
and I was and this camera right there
the second yeah that's in Africa yeah
yeah that's the one I want to show okay
and there's a party I see where you're
going but this is beautiful because this
is 1960 some it's not even about the
music in this
q up a little bit it's about the
percussion it's about the percussionist
and what he does okay so the guy is
playing bongos with sticks his name is
Roberto Rowena all right he said you
know with the [ __ ] earth wind fire
Sudan that the only the only pottery can
do one of their twin fire suna that's
Ray Barretto alright and then speed it
up a little bit late they start dancing
and singing and [ __ ] around and then
you gotta have to live over there you
got his knee over very you got an
all-star band Darren keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going and there's a scene here
where the bongo player starts dancing
but I want to hear to see what he's
doing right there go right there it's
like it watch what he's doing
this is 1973 Rick James alive from
Africa 71 this is or 73 or 74 this was
before Muhammad Ali thought uh one of
the big fights towards forming George
Foreman they decided to do a concert for
peace and they got BB King and you know
they got everybody the finally all stars
and they died this guy in that guy but
the most impressive was Rick chance no
was James Brown sorry but they came out
James Brown and a friend uh live I'm
sorry I'm [ __ ] Rick James we changed
this smoking crack from Buffalo the
payback yeah so this was the concert
before the fight watch but I don't even
know how old he is here but put this out
loud
got to be in his 30s by 40 maybe 40
this man will make your liver quit this
is Africa
this is next Bronx will more Los Angeles
this is nowhere this man will free me if
you will let's all welcome the world's
Godfather of Soul despair went from
being the Cape guide to the announcer
look at this look at this Savage he came
out with an entourage I use a boxing
body here we go here we go [ __ ] this was
Michael Jackson this oh yeah Prince he
showed him how this was you know I just
showed you a Spanish dude that nobody's
really heard him breakdancing in 1971
that was maybe 72 yeah it's the funny
All Stars big tapes were Japan Africa
and they did the Yankee Stadium and they
the Puerto Ricans danced so much but
that was the first time they were told
about canceling a baseball game the next
day half the field was [ __ ] torn up
here [ __ ] man that's awesome
and you still tour yeah now what more do
you tour with every other week like
every week would somebody [ __ ]
differently but you know you're with the
Beatles and actually Soundgarden you
know the last year and a half of been
juggling between you know Cypress Hill
and prophets of rage and down you know
I'll be on tour one month with this
group and then next month it'll be with
that group and just been going back and
forth like that and it don't stop you
know fortunately it's it's still fun and
still have a passion for music and
creating it and playing it so you know
it's uh you know it's fun you know
especially going from one one thing to
another one which is very hip-hop you
know it transcends hip-hop like in terms
of like our fan base you know they're
they like alternative music they like
the the rock and
[ __ ] metal [ __ ] as well as hip-hop you
know so there it's it's a different type
of energy but then you know you go with
the prophets of rage and these
[ __ ] just like rocking the [ __ ]
out so it's completely two completely
different energies but it's it's fun on
both ends it's so you know sometimes it
gets a little bit much because you know
you're away from home for so long and if
you you know I got a family so it's kind
of hard being away from the family so
much but in terms of you know what we've
been trying to do with it and you know
the point we're trying to get across
with the music and then just as artists
rock in the [ __ ] out you know it's
everything is is going really well you
know we've been touring a lot and we're
about to you know take these next two
months off three months whatever and
work on some new music for it as well as
we got some Cypress Hill music on deck
coming out like two albums a lot of
music you said before the podcast that
you're still having fun and you just
said it again you've been doing it for
at least 30 years it sounds like it
probably even more was that were there
times over that thirty years that it
wasn't fun that you didn't like it well
you know in this business it's just
shark-infested so you know it's always
gonna be having its ups and downs
because you know in the end you know
you're trying to put your music out
there you're trying to make a living
you're trying to you know do what do
what you love and all that stuff and
there's a lot of politics in between all
that it's more than just making an album
or a song and then putting it out and
then there's an explosion in you're
famous and all this sort of [ __ ] there's
a lot of stuff in between that and and
there's no actual school to teach you
the process kind of got to learn you
know hands-on you know as the steps
progress you know what I mean especially
in a hip hop and you know I wouldn't
take nothing back to be honest with you
you know the good times and bad times
make up what's happening right now you
know for better for worse and [ __ ] like
that and for me I consider you know all
that stuff you know that wasn't so great
learning experiences as opposed to you
know some negative [ __ ] where you know
to complain about something cuz who's
gonna listen wants to hear you complain
exactly yeah no I'm saying it nobody
wants to hear that so if I'm complaining
that means I'm bitter about some of the
losses I took so you know I'm never
bitter about that because the loss is a
learning experience if you if you look
at it the right way so you know I'm good
you know it's helped me all those things
helped me progress to where I am now
which allows me to be in two bands and
flip styles the way that you know I'm
able to do from one show to the other
and from once creating one style in
creating the other with the other guys
you know what I mean it all that stuff
led up to where I'm at now so you know
you take that if you're passionate about
what it is I mean it's like going up
there and having a routine and some of
the routine is hitting and some of it
you know you need to work on when you
when you go home right or the [ __ ]
[ __ ] bombs out like you could you could
say ah man I ain't going back up on the
mic I [ __ ] bombed out or you go back
and create something else that come back
out and [ __ ] tear their asses up
again you know it just depends on how
much passion you got for it and you know
I've always had a lot of passion for
music you know before I was even you
know creating it with my bros you know
so I for me it's it's all about that you
know still loving to do it do taking
risks you know that normally other
people won't take creatively stuff like
that man it's a love [ __ ] like that
because it's a challenge let's be
strictly honest here I pretty much
booked a podcast with me somebody calls
me
I talked to Louie he talks to me we put
his name down and we see where we're at
with that person
and it's funny that because of my
touring schedule and then I was trying
to write a sitcom Tuesday's war was
being rough for me plus an acting class
plus the baby yeah and finally when I
freed up so many people mentioned you to
me then it was overwhelming until I said
let me go down and see what this podcast
is about and from the minute I walked
into your studio you you're you know
what time you got there you know you
gentleman the staff you had I was very
taken aback by you but why you would do
not this I love to talk you know I'm
saying I still got that residue cocaine
from it comes up every once in a while
I swear every what's the one OK ROCK
like the corner factor and I can't it's
nothing I could say to you because I'm
listening to you and you're exactly on
the money but what I admire about you
the most is what happened to the spin
doctors listen I'm just acting me what
was the song they sang their they'll
enter their Aadhaar you now come out
better this time yeah karaoke now right
ok so it's a few and now I am NOT
pulling down to spend doctors no by no
means
they have big hits they had big hits and
then whatever happened one guy became a
carpenter the singer hated the piano
player know that you're the type of dude
that reinvents himself every 90 days and
then when that's how you keep yourself
fresh I had to go to my agent 2 months
ago and go listen I don't want to hear
about another date on the
again he said what are you talking about
you're selling now that's not the point
that's not the point scatter you
[ __ ] are wrong and then yeah
you make a little change and then you
buy a house and guess what now you're in
debt yeah now you're doing something
that you used to love but it became a
job yeah when you choose an art as a
career you want to get up tip-top
McGoohan attack at every day it's a lot
of it's a fine line I tell you and I
know you're gonna tell me when it was me
you this dude in fat [ __ ] Joe in a
garage with no money those are the best
times we have or just rapid and it was
just us guru making some good music also
something came in that was called money
and pressure and we adjusted weird that
that's what we do but it [ __ ] up the
main thing of what you're doing what
you're doing you know letting the money
get in the way you're switching it up
you're switching up I'm sitting here all
because I have a hard time raising a
daughter loving my wife because if you
know if you don't give your wife love
right then that's a completely different
thing I take it from massage yesterday
60 bucks to Chinese people we hold hands
together they put rocks on your neck
right I know what it puts a smile on
your face and that's it I want a half of
my time I got the podcast and then you
gotta go on the road right we don't have
I don't have all that [ __ ] I wish I had
the time and energy you know we make a
road I don't know where you live and I
don't give a [ __ ] but you gotta get on
that 4 or 5 - oh yeah when they put a
picture on Twitter oh yeah of the 405
that they don't know we live with that
that's serious so you go to visit
somebody as four [ __ ] hours yeah yeah
that had a man that's just getting there
let's just get there do it today or
Friday I had a meeting and on the way
back we call me there's how'd it go I go
what's gonna done on the phone we have
Skype this is why I admire you because
you find time to wait a second not just
tour people if all I had to do every
weekends
was go out and say the same jokes have
been saying for 10 years and nobody
would say nothing that's what I was
doing it'd be easy but I know you're the
type of dude that wants to create you
want to create and when you want to
create you have to find time to create
on top of being a dad you're writing
business because this whole business now
you got the set up which I admire again
you got 10 shows going on there you know
you're smoking your employees a giggling
everybody's hire 8:30 in the morning say
hi and reading Donuts they got tacos
[ __ ] Donuts you know I mean that's a
it as an artist point of view you have
the perfect artist life which is what
used to happen in this city as far as we
were concerned see as a comedian what
you did was be real got a she'll be real
call two weeks ago
you said he mentioned a restaurant he
wants you to be a garbage man in this
show be really give you 6 episodes out
of 13 every year that means four [ __ ]
eight weeks I'm not gonna do dick 20
times yet for six weeks I'm just gonna
focus on be real show right what I gotta
call be real and tell be real real
they're gonna shoot me out Tuesday cuz I
got a gig in Philadelphia on Thursday
and guess what I'm not gonna be
effective on your show and I'm not gonna
be effective in Philadelphia because I'm
thinking about both tanks right let me
just focus on the real thing
kill that [ __ ] so the next season that
[ __ ] brings me back for eight
shells or season okay so you had that
breather in today's comedic world you
don't have that no more yeah they found
out they can make money with you why why
[ __ ] with the nest yeah keep them on the
road keep them on the road keep them on
the road until we stop selling tickets
now you're 48 and you have no acting
experience so it hit you [ __ ] you gotta
[ __ ] I'm happy a surgery in a couple
weeks I mean 60 days I can't go on the
[ __ ] rope my age to go crazy I don't
give a [ __ ] yeah I don't give a [ __ ]
this is what being an artist is that for
30 days you go into a Denny's
you get the waitress offending you don't
only know but my buddy go back to that
section back there you
I'm gonna be there all day I'm lab eggs
I'm gonna have the pot roast on the
[ __ ] blood but I'm gonna stick it
out every day till 5:00 right it's
really weird the creative process
everybody has a different process simply
has a different process I know if I
overstock you a business how the [ __ ]
you gonna write lyrics yeah it's you
know it's tough juggling you know and
it's it's sort of like when it's all
going well you have to keep it going so
you got to keep everything [ __ ] in
the air and and keep it balanced for me
like I said I love challenges and in
terms of that challenge and the
reinventing myself through different
projects different groups different
albums or whether it's solo or with
somebody you know that's something
Buster I'm talked to me about like in
the mid 90s when he had left one group
to do his solo [ __ ] and it was
tremendously different and you know he
pulled me to the side one day and he
said hey man you know you should um in
his Busta Rhymes voice yo yo yo son you
need you know you need to be constantly
doing [ __ ] and reinventing yourself be
you know do [ __ ] different know you got
this group but do do other things and
that was a bad impression of him but you
know cuz I'm not really on my game right
now I usually do Busta Rhymes voice
pretty good but today I [ __ ] the pot but
you know he gave me that advice and I
kind of was hesitant at that time
because uh you know I was all about
Cypress Hill and I said well you know
this is where my 100% focuses why would
I you know why would I [ __ ] that up by
going and doing some solo [ __ ] and you
know just doing some crazy [ __ ] when
things are going so well you know I was
very focused like you said instead of
trying you know having all these
different things going on I was very
much all about the group and years later
that's when I started thinking you know
uh all right well I've done a lot of
[ __ ] with the group let me
start doing some different things here
and there and I did a couple of mixtapes
and it did a solo album and you know
went back and started doing some group
[ __ ] and then I created another group
with the exhibit and this cat named
Derek Derek called serial killers and we
did a hardcore hip-hop album under that
group for two albums and then I
partnered up after that with with burner
which we did three three albums called
prohibition what they were two EPs and
one album and you know all that while I
was doing it as another solo album that
I gave away which was called the
prescription and you know I just kept
you know writing and writing for
different things you know doing
collaborations with other people and
just keeping the Busta Rhymes [ __ ] in
mind at that point like okay if I'm not
gonna if I'm gonna do something away
from Cypress I don't want to do anything
like I do with Cypress on this other
[ __ ] so I'm gonna be something
completely different on this something's
a different side of me
on this [ __ ] as opposed to what people
are used to seeing with me with Cypress
so you know I just took that from one
group to another and even with prophets
like the way I'm dressed up there with
with prophets is completely different
than what I do with Cypress and you know
that's to have that distinction to have
something different and you know then to
make people ask why cuz you know people
are always gonna be like well why is he
why is didn't like to just look over
here is so extreme you know but that's
the thing you know you reinvent yourself
and you make people [ __ ] ask
questions and boom you've done your
[ __ ] job you know what I mean so I'm
just used to like taking these things on
in and given everything a different kind
of different kind of feel to it so it's
not a reagent ated thing of what we do
with cyprus cuz I mean you know if I'm
going to do that
just stay doing the [ __ ] I do with
Cypress he says that you've worked with
everybody in the business even our the
boy Danny Brown I mean you can he's a
little - Danny Brown like a brother he's
a good dude and it's just you continue
to grow you don't stop I don't stop
there's no or there's no and it's not
like you ever noticed when the dude is
progressing and he tries to act young
that's not you at all it's he I could
see it when you sing it when you were
kid you're like Spanish music yeah yeah
hold on let me open the door before they
call my gun
I actually did one of the other shows I
did we don't smoke the same oh you did
we don't smoke this and like that was
even before I met you it like there's a
lot of people in this town who don't
like to promote people around them and
what I really liked was a zone said he
worked for you and like up he gets to do
the show now so it's like and then our
other friend Roz dude we've known I've
known for years 18 months with you for
years I'm pretty sure so it's it's just
nice to see people who act loyally and
are nice and let's now oh well you know
when we started be real TV you know and
and it was called the 4/20 show as
opposed to dr. greenthumb show we
changed it later because you know I said
[ __ ] it you know there's a lot of 4/20
shows there's not a dr. greenthumb show
on dr. greenthumb [ __ ] it so I switched
the name and it started maybe with six
people maybe less than that
I think those four people myself a
couple of DJs and that you know my
partner in in the network and you know
we we started off with the one show just
because I realized the importance of a
platform because they used to do a radio
show on 92.3 the beat called the Seoul
assassins show which is different than
the show that DJ Muggs does unserious no
but you know this was in the kind of
late 90s in it and you know we did some
big things on the radio so you know when
I left
due to politics you know there I was
searching for a platform the streaming
became the thing and I got into that and
little by little I just you know as I we
build our own platform in the streaming
world
I started recruiting other shows other
people and you know some of our staff
started as people in the chat room like
that we would have this back-and-forth
engagement like so our guy we got a guy
called cheeky I was lucky
yeah cheeky cheeky Delic we called but
at first you know his his name in the
chat room was Iron Sheik him in him and
I would have some crazy exchanges in the
chat room talking major [ __ ] to each
other but on some joke [ __ ] but like on
some really foul joke [ __ ] you know what
I mean because you know we that's how we
interacted with our chat room we would
call it the freezer cuz it was based off
of insults you know we've just insult
the [ __ ] out of each other
he made insult us we didn't salt them
but it was all you know love [ __ ] we
realized that she was a wordsmith you
know he he could you know he could hang
with the [ __ ] best of them we invited
him down to the studio and he became you
know a writer for the site in the
beginning then he became an operator and
then you know eventually you know part
of the show and with Eze own he started
as an intern you know doing like stories
and [ __ ] like that for the site as well
because you know our site does stream
and blog and you know eventually we
asked him to do you know to help co-host
the show with us be up there at the
table when we felt he was ready and then
we gave him his own show you know the
the live platform and our YouTube so we
give to different shows as you know he's
been around and you know he earned his
way up and then Roz dude started as an
intern went into you know an operator
position and now he's creating content
through his alley review so you know we
try to step everybody up in some former
Nell's started up with us as a DJ DJ
Nels
and you know he became one of the
co-hosts of the show and you know he
coordinates the smoke box and stuff like
that so you know all of our guys have
been with us for a long time so we just
try to create roles for everybody as we
go along then you know sometimes there's
no job description coming if there ain't
no job description so so it's like you
get in where you know long probably go
no I'm pretty sure someone's
jackhammering at 8:30 at night you know
you would give me like you felt I was
farting when you were at their first
though that's the fire alarm guys
hysterical I told you the final part was
over here and I've been on I don't give
a [ __ ] we don't know look we haven't
been here in hours yeah
is that them coming right now I see the
red lights oh no will you Medusa on my
head spin knickers I just went into a
different I'm sorry guys I don't that's
a first for everybody I will be moving
into the studio come on oh there goes a
talk oh you're absolutely right god damn
it
how do you go it just my off let's just
went off they shut it off they notice
the building is not on fire they'll be
come in here to do the walkthrough hi
guys everything okay yes sir this
everything is fine there's nothing to
see here as cop cars out there and fire
department so should we put away some of
this [ __ ] no we live like doctors we got
loss we got rules that we have it in
said there ain't nobody out there what
the [ __ ] is wrong with you we have in my
heart being on my chest you we had an
incentive offer yeah oh yeah oh my god
this is way better than when the notary
Republic knocked on the door you know
it's crazy how are they always tell you
to reinvent yourself you know in this
career that didn't seem like you
reinvented yourself that's not the word
for what you did you explored right
that's a complete different [ __ ]
animal
Debra but see there's somebody out there
something going on that I turn my phone
on does heal it landlord no no it's like
people with weapons oh my god somebody's
I don't give a [ __ ] we got weapons no
weapons we got what they look with Jesus
Christ you
yeah I guess somebody's out there
oh yeah it's gonna do yeah you guys
remember we used to smoke dope with that
one building and the black lady been one
of the dawning times we were getting
high and then hysterical we didn't even
get high in there it was Felipe
everybody Felipe went going crazy and
then we're in the other time it was the
earthquake that time at 7:00 the more my
grandma's I'm [ __ ] camera you see the
[ __ ] earthquake only on a podcast
brother crazy and then doing the we see
you come home from the tour I'm telling
you cuz this [ __ ] baffles me Ron white
60 runway goes on the road every weekend
Friday and Saturday like nothing there
are people if I go on the road for weeks
in a row I wake up I don't know what the
[ __ ] I am the other day when I came back
from New York that Monday I took a nap
after jujitsu and I went to bed at 2:00
one third and I woke up at 5:00 man
unless they didn't know it was 5:00 in
the morning or 5:00 in the afternoon so
my wife came and said for me I'm gonna
pick up the baby hmm
like I just drove me off completely so I
gotta get my [ __ ] together I gotta get
my game up like be real take vitamins to
sleep more or do some [ __ ] yeah man you
know I truthfully I trained for this
[ __ ] it's hard man you get older you
know and you do a show at the pace that
we do it you know that our music is that
because when you think about it and I
don't think people do the math on this
but you know certain groups when they do
shows especially with Golden Age hip-hop
shows they try to keep the music moving
and up tempo so a lot of the songs are
about 100 100 beats per BPM and
sometimes faster and a lot of the songs
that like stir people up or at that
temple so when you got to do an hour and
a half
that's like cardio you know I mean
there's a lot of words you're spitting
out there and moving around and you know
as you get older you better be active
and doing [ __ ] to be able to do though
type of songs at the at the highest
level that that you can't you know what
I mean and for me you know for a second
I was just kind of letting go and doing
whatever and I gained a whole lot of
weight but I was still doing the shows
but I you know given a hundred percent
with all that weight but the way that I
felt after the show was [ __ ] crazy
out glad to jump in buckets of ice and
[ __ ] and it was tough you know what I
mean so I I thought to myself I'm gonna
keep doing this and this shit's still
gonna be fun and not paying for I got to
take better care of myself and I started
you know eating better and you know
working out you know aside from just
doing the shows and stuff like keeping
active so that I could do those shows so
I could endure the hour and a half you
know and then when I started doing the
prophets of rage [ __ ] you know I'd
realized that I had to step up the
workouts cuz those shows are even harder
they were hard then then then the
cypress shells just because the
intensity of the songs are you know
there are different lemon juice rivers
yeah yeah dude river song okay so trip
this out you know I keep doubt on this
right you know somewhat where my watch
and [ __ ] and you know that thing has an
app that counts your steps and calories
and all this sort of [ __ ] right so
it'll count your steps and lay it out in
miles so you know I did a Cypress show
at an hour and a half and it came to
about four miles something you know four
point something miles right did it
prophets afraid show at an hour and a
half and it was like eight miles that's
how much you know more movement how much
more energy there was on that show and
that's not taking away anything with
Cypress it's just it's a different sort
of body language different sort of
energy different kind of movement and
man I lost a lot of weight on that
prophets of rates do it
all the way before I got into comedy
goddess this was maybe the beginning of
calmly I was friends with this dude and
he worked at the University of Colorado
with Denver campus in the music
department and what his specialty was
Cypress Hill was going on tour they have
a choreographer told you to find
apartments it but he was I asked the
neighbor but he would come in to clean
up your movements hmm so he we're eating
dinner when they were friends from that
feller he was over a table
we went my friend's restaurant because
he was in the halfway house for a while
how was the halfway house the rest day I
guess and when he told us what he did
and then he died like I'm like so tell
me this again he goes disc and at the
time I've had I don't remember but his
biggest client that I was there when she
was in town before the tour started was
chanting Jack's really nice and he told
me right on he goes you gotta know one
thing about these people they're normal
people he goes pretty much before the
tour starts I fly out to LA I meet with
their trainer and that explains them the
movements and the endurance and because
those tours there's movement you know
it's like you're chanting dance a lot
they dance a lot and he goes well
celebrities don't take it seriously so
Janet would show up 10 pounds overweight
and the tours a week away she goes
here's the funny thing that in the
beginning of the tour and everybody
knows this 70% of vocals a lip-sync
because of cardio you can't do the whole
thing yeah by to 60 days in she's it you
know I'm saying he's doing all my own
shake of all that and I still remember
signing with this agent and bro I had an
hour he was there but it was an hour of
just material yeah and I still remember
going I'm headlining Brian headline and
it took me like a year to learn how to
headline to get her chops for headline
when I start a headline
listen Bob always doing something four
days a week I walk I throw kettlebells I
gonna do Jitsu I swim when I do two
shows on a Friday and I'm Pro when I get
back to my hotel room it's like I got
beat up by ten [ __ ] white bucks from
my hips down
I could feel and then say I gotta take
two of those Tylenol PM or not not the
PM's a regular table and it's so we and
how you have to get into
touring shape yeah and if you eat [ __ ]
you're dead yeah and you know yeah
you're dead you know if you're not 22 no
more
then drink a bottle of tequila when you
wake up and done you know exists it
doesn't it doesn't get any easier
it's [ __ ] my house how you read about
the reason why you get partly until you
feel this depression the beginning is
for the party and then after you do two
or three tours living there you go wait
a second this ain't the way to [ __ ]
do this I gotta chop something up the
women gotta go the power gotta go to do
to have the powder gotta go everybody
gotta [ __ ] everybody gotta go
it gets heavy men you know because what
what what you have available to you at
that point is whatever you want and you
will indulge in it if the wrong
[ __ ] around you know and that's
that's the thing and then that [ __ ]
starts wearing Tarrant on your [ __ ]
body adds years to it and you know then
you're spending time after that trying
to recover from that [ __ ] and you know I
think if you take care of yourself
obviously give yourself more years and
you know you're doing yourself a favor
and at that point it but at this at this
point you know like if you're still as a
as a so-called Golden Age rapper or
golden era hip-hop rapper I should say
you know a lot of us still do a lot of
shows you know not not just Cypress but
a lot of cats from that time and what
you see now is a lot of these guys are
now training getting in shape like look
at red man for instance you know he
trains all the time he's a fitness
[ __ ] junkie but really that's that
you know for his health and to be able
to do those shows on the highest level
that Fat Joe and Fat Joe normal yeah he
slimmed out to I mean you know you
everybody's more or less taking care of
themselves a little bit better than the
generation perform and I think you're
gonna see more of that and that's good
man you know cuz there wasn't as much
education on how to take care of
yourself eating right and the right
workouts for you know different people
because everybody there everybody's body
and you know responds to something
different you know so well the first
general road you don't know your
boundaries and people fighting you this
[ __ ] and you're eating like a savage
you're you doing it wrong to drink if
you're consuming consuming every waking
up from Radio which let me tell you
something that if you have drugs women
shows the worst thing on everything that
if you don't do it really makes you fall
apart asleep I didn't know this when I
got older and I got sleep apnea and they
were like you're Lloyd did you sleep six
hours yeah you sleep but you don't
recover you don't recover mentally or
physically three or four nights of that
[ __ ] you're forgetting your lyrics up on
stage you know rancors you're not see
that show not getting a full sleep you
gotta sleep that working out makes you
sharper putting your pen on the [ __ ]
piece of paper it all helps out and it's
weird on my life is I've been doing 20
weeks a year twenty four twenty twenty
five plus the
last five years li and finally I go you
know I I gotta slow down a little bit
this year get my ear fix from the flying
yeah I used to swim in the pools and the
water stays in there that I can't
[ __ ] hear for four [ __ ] days then
I get equilibrium I got nausea
all right so need that [ __ ] you're doing
a New Year's Eve show not not that I
know of why me we used to do him in New
York City you know once upon a time but
then we shifted over to to doing
Halloween but it would be cool to to do
a show [ __ ] [ __ ] losing you New
Year's Eve just you know the right
scenario I guess but yeah we haven't
played on New Year's Eve since [ __ ] I
can't I can't even remember it's been so
long now hope you go into the studio
with next is it Cyprus or well you know
right now we're finishing mixes on on
cypresses two albums right now mugs is
finishing the mixes on on the album that
he produced and then there's another one
that was produced by another producer
and he's in the middle of mixing those
songs so you know right now we're we're
in finish up mode but so the next time
but the next time I'm in the studio to
like create some new [ __ ] is with
prophets of rage in in the next couple
months we're gonna start working on
another album and I'll just be flooded
with music next year yeah it's been
impressive dude man
to juggle all that [ __ ] and calls from
your agents and lawyers that drives me
up a [ __ ] war yeah you know everybody
tries to pull you a different way man
but you know you kind of got to stay the
course that you want to be on and you
know fortunately I got two bands with
band mates that are very understanding
cool dudes to be around like good people
funny as hell
Goutham prophets arranged prophets of
Rage is Tom Morello Chuck D Tim
Commerford
dad woke in DJ Lord and myself and
that's two guys from Public Enemy which
is DJ Lord and and uh it's Chuck D and
Rage Against the Machine so three guys
from reddit Rage Against the Machine
Timmy see Brad Wilk and Tom Morello and
myself from sighs I saw Morello story
what was on Sunset next to coffee bean
on Fairfax
not now now it's a burger place before
that it was something different maybe it
was a Mexican joint it was something
[ __ ] up there yes it was it was a
burrito joint where those California
burrito joints I'm talking 2001 that way
I used to cop on Fairfax reefer so I
would walk over there and then be hungry
and all that whatever it was them
sitting outside one day and then he was
Tom Morello by himself II who's on the
way I drew in the garbage
I don't bother people he said hello to
me and I don't know you I we [ __ ] I
think I am was much smoking too much
weed he was no it's me to meet you and
that was it nice guy cool dude and I
didn't ask him for a picture
you know me dawg I wanna pick your house
do it you know yeah yeah that's the
thing I don't wanna do it he was sitting
in the middle of bite yes yes it was a
burrito place cuz I used to go and then
get the meat the long meat tacos and
sugar for murder baby why need no there
wasn't it one it was like a chain it
really was a good chain before that
whole thing became what it was will
doesn't matter I was just doing my boy
yeah yeah I've been told nice one time
he was a [ __ ] gentleman no he's a
good guy he he you don't mind taking
pictures for the fence you know you
don't you don't you don't turn anybody
down that's not like about these guys is
that dealt those take the time for fans
sometimes with the blue Penner's you
know they give those guys a hard time
they'll make him work for it what's my
name
if you don't know my name I'm not
signing yeah
[ __ ] like that you know I'm not really
familiar with the music industry for
like the last 10 years of the comedy
industry they were doing a lot of self
releasing and publicly do you put out
this stuff by yourself are you on and
out like a label or uh I put out the
prescription stuff by myself you know
it was just I put it up on I believe it
was live mixtape calm and doubt piff and
let let it be shared out from there
and then put it on the soundcloud and
and did that so yeah you know we did it
a hundred percent independent and gave
it out a hundred percent for free you
know in terms of doing an independent
album that did I sold I did one with
duck down records called smoke and
mirrors many years back and that was my
one and only like endeavor and doing a
solo album and selling it you know like
with uh with some of the music as of
late I've just given it out and you know
in terms of the hip-hop [ __ ] but I
figured you know man I've been in the
game for twenty twenty-five years and at
the time I was doing these mixtape bit
or at this particular mixtape which was
called the prescription it wasn't even a
mixtape it was an album I just gave it
out for free I thought you know I've
been in this game for for this long let
me let me give the fans something
special you know that they don't have to
pay for and it's just one of those
things worth you know we gave him free
music and it worked out for me a lot of
people love that [ __ ] and you know I
made videos for proper like any album
any other album and you know I did many
shows off off of those songs and stuff
like that so it did you know I managed
to do some solo work in there and but
mostly you know I've been about the
group's but you know like I say you know
I don't mind juggling I don't mind the
challenge you got balls of steel brother
and then listen that's what it takes
that's what it takes
it's not that even nobody saying no to
you and yes you know it's not like your
Alanis Morissette
another song that thing bomb let you
come back singing top 10 yeah and he
scratched my back and [ __ ] me in a
movie Tina you never say no it's it's
not that those lyrics to the song
whatever the [ __ ] they are close enough
and you came in my mouth and you closed
your eyes every time she scratched your
name I hope you I hope you feel it I
hope you feel it well I'm here to tell
Harvey whatever the [ __ ] to remind
Harvey ah this is a reminder you can get
away [ __ ] there might be a rehab
but when you get on him firmly a
statement oh yeah
you think he's getting off for that just
because he did rehab he's trying to
obviously first off this [ __ ] trick
in the book
me and my buddies were pulling that one
an 84 ounces of blow you make bail you
go to your house you hug your mother you
do one last line and you go to the
nearest rehab and you tell them to
smuggle you in coke if they give you a
you stick to it you get a Bible you go
to church you put a [ __ ] camera on
you you have people follow you and take
pictures of it that is the oldest scam
in the book it's like right now I go out
would be real and lee-sia me and me will
would three in a car at the light we
make a light and some guy says something
to us he pulls a gun out Lisa Ann has a
gun he shoots a guy dead the guy shoots
be real in the leg I should I take the
leaf from I think the gun from me I
shoot another guy dead that's what
happens I fake a heart attack I don't
know nothing until I string our stories
together and you fail yeah what like I'd
seen from Boogie Nights which one with
the guy what they got was the guy it was
going crazy am I the guy
ran the stereo store oh yeah yeah yeah
you faked a heart attack for money you
always faked a heart attack and you
gives you at 72 hours to come up with
the thing your attorney sits at the door
and I call b-real on the Batphone not
the line lines but the bat bat bat phone
and then b-real tells me no I shot the
guy that guy's got your fingerprints and
then I come back I don't know nothing be
real got shot and he fell on me and I
was holding the gun the gun must have
gotten fired but before the cops came I
pull out qahal on my head to eliminate
the Illuminati yeah you always you know
they go and they do the obvious which
makes them seem even more I mean he's
buried he's done he's done because he'd
left a trail of paperwork right he's
left a horrible trail of paper he did
destruction that undestructible but it's
the way in the world you play with fire
you know saying if you follow me though
yeah you did this the old American Way a
lot of people come here they're naive
they came up with some money next thing
you know they're telling you your dog to
be in this rap group you gotta carry a
key over to Denver
yeah you know have to be part of our
[ __ ] Swami salami thing a [ __ ] you
know non you know it's it's crazy what
happens in this industry to people it's
a shame what happened to those girls I
also want the name of the agents that
sent them over there yeah cuz they knew
what was crying a lot and they knew this
guy was gonna get open up the door to
roam all those strawberries all them
[ __ ] knew about him yes they
did
yes they did you know so those they can
all be guilty of the same [ __ ] what
saying some you talked about them at the
beginning of the podcast what about the
mothers who agreed to let one more date
their daughter that [ __ ] wasn't
allowed at the mall you think about that
for 10 minutes you go home tomorrow when
you ain't thinking about your children
or what's important go wait a second I
bet I'm 40 some years oh I'm a grown man
nobody's ever thrown me out of a [ __ ]
morning and I shoplift from GNC since
the age of two
right everybody's told something from
GNC not muscle dick pills a lower cream
what is that hello Aloha
you know nobody gets stronger than the
mall they made this [ __ ] get out
of the mall for just abducting little 16
year old dog waiting on them eight of
them that is the other side of the coin
let me tell you what the other side of
the coin okay my brother you're very
fortunate you grew up in Downey now
pretty much like Easton Ilana
yeah migrated to California right away
68 when did she know stops now she
escaped right she escaped yeah then we
have 68 you were escaping yeah we got
Maggie go on now she came in through it
was either at the port of Florida or New
York somewhere around there because she
ended up in California she she had a
cousin here then came in on the lottery
system you know how in Cuba they got a
lottery system and if one of your kids
numbers pops up in that lottery system
they give you the option to leave the
island but you give up your you know all
your credentials your citizenship there
and they let you go but you got to start
over and you know so you know if you
were a professor if you're a doctor if
you were a physicist if you are anything
like that when you were going to the
United States you weren't going to with
none of those credential right so you
know there was a family that you know my
mother's family knew and they were going
to the states they didn't have no kids
like it guess apparently the the the
daughter had passed away recently and
they passed my cousin for this this girl
and she went with that family came into
the United States and kind of grew up
here and when my mother escaped she was
the only relative here you know that was
from you know her family and so you know
if she was here she was living and I
think Inglewood California mom came
wrath
plenty eye raft no [ __ ] yes she escaped
from prison actually she had a she had a
cousin that was you know communist and
worked in the prison and she was
anti-communism obviously which was why
she was in prison
and you know he kind of helped her to
get out of there because you know the
future was not right for her in there so
she escaped from the prison then escaped
from the island on a raft and you know
ended up in the United States our moms
have similar my mom grew up with you but
my brothers my sisters the whole [ __ ]
deal
shitty [ __ ] neighborhood when she was
16 and her sister was 15 a brother they
all went to a dance or violet and my mom
couldn't find her younger sister so she
went outside she heard a noise that some
guy was raping her in a bush so my mom
got a bow and stabbed the guy the guy
died my mom had to get rushed out of
Cuba that leg went to the Bronx and then
went back doc the alias and that's why I
never got Social Security what a weird
[ __ ] crazy
escape on a raft and via heaven you know
if people ever thought about like when I
watch that our 4:30 4:30 that's the
first time I didn't sleep about
something without doing meth or coke for
four years just deeply so have you ever
watched it yeah 34 30 what the two Cuban
brothers I know the pictures no I'm not
I got stuck in the Bahamas and they had
leads in three days and they told her
buddy his hand and you know you know who
the [ __ ] thinks this [ __ ] up in science
crazy
and if Castro would have caught him his
brother had just won the war I've on
well Ivana then the other guy went to
the Yankees and he became a legend for
the Yankees with the high leg kick and
[ __ ] I think about how [ __ ] lucky I
was and my mom got me out of there with
did I'm thinking power [ __ ] but I got a
New York City birth certificate j-money
hmm
that's how kinky the system was there
yeah were you influenced by the Cuban
music I mean you know she used to listen
to my mother you solicit to a lot of the
stuff that she you know was able to find
it was you know like Cuban music Cuban
bands and stuff like that so yeah you
know I grew up listening to celeea goose
and you know [ __ ] like that yeah we have
a cat named many money
yeah please did you know here his
records to the ground count gumbo and
girl on cold water and man do me a favor
Lee yes put on for my brother here just
so you can see our roots
what would you eat off my pants ah Jesus
these [ __ ] are bad brother
but brother these guys eat like beans
once a month okay yeah I want you to
show you how happy they are because
talking to you makes me think that
you're related to these [ __ ] on
one another and you never know man like
Samoans harem you and I q UI TOS loafs l
OS Moony Iquitos daddy Matanzas Mata and
zas gotcha
let's see what you got up there watch
these [ __ ] this is this is your
cousins in Cuba right here I know this
for a fact or after talking to you the
scroll scroll down scroll down keep
going
I'm just trying it to go I believe
there's one video right there that one
right there click this you gotta watch
these [ __ ] he's a hyung click
down and go away please you're killing
me I'm gonna have to stab you with a
pencil huh
what's this listen to this music that's
this change how would you like them to
marry this distance anything I'd go to
Cuba on a sailboat and smuggle a'ready
you see this little black guy he's about
90 to Lee but he's been doing this every
day that's why he's in tremendous shape
without the Cubans they go for the [ __ ]
watch this old school fuse with the
thumb what is on the bomb dog this is
bro age but his word got infected dope
they invented this again this came from
Africa there yeah that's it this is 2nd
generation without Z covers that monkeys
look at the chubby Cuba's a flight in
your place after she danced around to
this I want anyone to put on my face but
that wouldn't be bad that'd be a decent
one
we put that back that cyclist I can be
sweet with the plantain with that back
ten seconds four seconds this is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that guy's 90 years old right there
these are pretty good you have a good
[ __ ] for a beer Oh [ __ ] I'm
always I could move like that in ninety
weather
oh my god hey guys yeah these guys get
like $8 a month to do that and they put
that nut bro
these guys tour all over the world when
you go see these guys your [ __ ] jaw
drops I saw him in Boulder and like 90
[ __ ] three at the Fox Theatre my
friend called me she goes you know I'm
gonna keep those at the [ __ ] down what
are you talking about
she's a brother gonna be every security
but you get in there and they were
[ __ ] phenomenal and they try out you
know like my cousins are the other ones
my cousins are Hecky Alfonso and mei-fun
so put a key Alphonse more from with the
guitar on Vale he I just would yell that
me and my wife was sitting there and
Anthony Bourdain's in Puerto Rico and
all sudden the next one is Cuba and
we're sitting there my wife gets up I
got honey get in here my cousin's on
[ __ ] anthony bourdain
ve oh this is the [ __ ] that put nada out
of Cuba be real any time you want to go
to this club in Cuba la factorio
y'all I got to do is make the call
you're doing it all wrong aqui our fight
so with an a right there the first one
Vail
can you believe it was there and he mess
it up again
oh there you go alright listen to what
they're doing down in Cuba dawg this is
my cousin blood blood his farm is my
uncle
brother you know you can't deny it all
those little things are pieces of who
you are then on top of that your uncle's
our mariachi you throw that [ __ ] haha
who the [ __ ] on the stop be really
shaking on the sand you got the mind of
a Cuban in the back of the Mexican yeah
you never met a Mexican on workman's
comp never you never see if they keep
right you never see a man I'm in well I
bought that way [ __ ] no Mexicans I know
Mexican fell off a roof he went to work
the next day when tend to happen next
day I don't miss a day but even called
the phone I even thought the call not in
the freaking associates he wouldn't go
for it oh yeah but oh yeah I will wait
yeah you know let me give a shout out
brother will get you forgot e it has
been your very fascinating and that's
it's it's amazing that we haven't
crossed paths before and now it was only
a matter of time you know I want to do
something with you for the simple reason
is that I learned something and will
really take it to the next [ __ ]
level do me a favor my little room can
you close that door look at this place
the alarm already went off one [ __ ]
time Jordan Karkat ha 22 B 2 B D guy 13
ace hole my brother down and under the
Australian warrior not so gingerly Cove
gold flavor
Mikey Cooper jouji boy and beto al Ron
what are you [ __ ] nuts or what now
are you in for the month of December
yeah yeah I mean you know we got a
couple of shells but they're pretty much
in California so you know we're home
well and then December you also write
every day do you write you have a
collaborator yeah I mean you know we
write you know for profits I write for
ciphers are right for myself I write for
for others and stuff like that in terms
of music and then you know with terms of
be real TV and content you know we all
sort of brainstorm and you know try to
come up with ideas there and stuff so
you know we all
you know sort of do that creative part
together but musically you know when it
comes to you know writing yeah I get in
his own and and I do my part
he don't be real uh I looked around your
place and you know when you see
something it feels right here we go
somewhere and you're like you know what
bro this other place got the view will
[ __ ] downtown LA and I'm looking at
white beep weed and that's your Paul
Klee and [ __ ] you know say but I felt
like ours and uh and I'm not a hippie
bro I've never been a hippie but I felt
I felt like I was at a place where I
could smoke a joint at your place and
going to a corner and write a bit I
would even consider doing like stand-up
and streamer from there yeah I can
totally do that do there's so many
things I want to do with you from down
there there's a lot of things I want to
do but again I'm like you bro I don't
know at the time I got some time to [ __ ]
around would be [ __ ] with you I
can tell you what I want to do you know
what bro try this way cuz we could do
this way this I could drop now at 8:30
instead of 10:30
don't curse on this bit you know I'm
saying like something yeah yeah I mean
for us it's all on here it's all
unfiltered but that's the thing I really
want to do some listen
brother be near us to sit somewhere it's
that smoking reefer what am i 13 and
I've been doing that on periscope every
morning that's how I motivate the troops
yeah I get on periscope nighttime to
watch their [ __ ] a little cup of coffee
some bong hits and away you go on that
bus happy then [ __ ] [ __ ] them you're
not gonna bust so but that's one thing
you're angry
yeah and that do smells like [ __ ]
dick or you wanna bust owns a completely
different situation oh yeah we tend to
overlook oh you took the bus driver is
[ __ ] if you give the bus driver a dollar
bill have a good day kind of sucker on
the way out but I admire what you're
doing I don't know sometimes I feel like
I'm not doing enough but at the same
time I am doing a lot he's doing a lot
you know plus the reefer plus sir
the number one thing is trying to stay
alive the next day for me I try to train
or lift weights and do push-ups and he's
an academic and store soda that you know
what but he's soon I might have to give
up smoking reefer my lungs uh this is
since I was 12 and I lived in Colorado
for maybe three the mainly file in that
altitude my lungs got acclimated
but between the crack the reefer the bug
in the [ __ ] you know sometimes when
you snorted coke you snort sheetrock and
she pubic hair who knows what happened
to my lung I got the nose fixed
and I'm still lacking oxygen so I hold
on everyday I got on it
I got chute export and it expands my
lungs you could always keep up the
edibles if you you know so nothing gonna
cut animals to ten milligrams you know
many edibles listen isn't have to eat
double there's some mornings I didn't
know eight doubles there's some mornings
dog where I eat animals late so many of
them that is true the next morning when
you're [ __ ] you could smell a
gelatin in this [ __ ] like a little like
a little like of this you could smell
the gelatin or it smells like wheat or
it smells like weed it feels over if
it's dosed heavy you're just I don't
like wheat I'm crazy it's terrible it's
terrible it's the craziest [ __ ] as in
you gonna acupuncture what's the deal
with you
neck and little smoke comes out like
that's when you know we [ __ ] yet and you
acupuncture I feel how much how you
still smoke last time I went does it say
we still smoking heavy no I gave it up
for [ __ ] the jeweler yeah [ __ ]
heavy and it's not like when I was 28
heavy I smoked in the morning I smoked
when I get back to jujitsu
still morning I smoked at about 4:00
afternoon I smoked at about 6:00 you
smoked a little bit before you watch TV
at 9:00 that's it it's not like that
when you're in the studio all day and
you got 20 people around you like your
partner over here and he's giving you a
joint every 7 minutes every 7 minutes
you had a joint for us is [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] tremendous you bring him
everywhere you take him on the road he's
your partner like he comes through some
of the LA stuff cuz he sees studio
manages be real TV so he stays home and
make sure it's all running properly when
my social scarf is leaving here maybe he
can help me run my business stay I'll
keep up my life he holds it down with
the truth keep him honest be real - a
real pleasure brother thanks for having
me brother man I appreciate that you uh
took the time I loved I've got a great
response from all in the [ __ ] in the box
the box of debt I love that I got in
there early I didn't need an ambulance
[ __ ] and I think I hope a lot of people
this is podcast because they they really
learned something they didn't learn
about the music industry or you know how
to make a million dollars they learn how
to be an artist or rich which I think a
lot of people have forgotten you know
what bro for the first 15 years I was
doing this people go to me you know what
he's all about don't a good time what
are this be talking about yeah but for
the last three I felt something
different you know you have to respect
it you have to see how it's affected it
I couldn't wait to [ __ ] go
stages 7:30 at night but wait if you
said to me listen there's a blonde in
the next room with a coke rock and a
clip ready to pop a nut or you get on
stage I tell them they're gonna get on
stage now there's times yeah I don't
wanna go on stage yeah so you have to
know what the strike went to sit home
right and that you proved a lot of
things to me maybe I'll do something
else I'll work the circus after year ha
ha ha comedy the other half and I'll
[ __ ] take over this world man good
luck to you over there lights you're
always welcome on here you have any tour
date you want to promote brother
we got December 1st with the Cypress
Hill um
kings of the West it's gonna be it's
gonna be partners gonna have ice cube
Snoop Dogg and ourselves and a couple of
others it's gonna be a really heavy gig
it's the first time the three of us have
been on the three groups have been on
stage in one place in Los Angeles kill
California and I don't know how long so
it's so it's a pretty big deal at one
and then you know with profits we have
almost acoustic Christmas coming up I
can't remember the date for that one I'm
high as hell but I feeling me to really
know you know I ran all the questions I
forgot whatever I want to last you
brought mixed tapes to differences but
even if you explain it to me I'm gonna
remember I'm like Cosby's victims right
now I wake up in the morning confused
and know what happened I know he showed
me his dick but I don't know what
happened after that
because I saw you have a couple of
mixtapes you know a mixtape is something
you make where well you know it's just
you make sorry to break your balls well
last time this is same thing you know
like if you're gonna make a mixtape it's
just like making an album the difference
is you're just calling it a mixtape and
giving it out for free and usually with
the mixtape it's with songs of samples
that you can't necessarily clear and
more aggressive songs that you wouldn't
necessarily put on your album and you
know a lot of artists gotten to do it
not 50 cent you know was very heavy with
mixtapes made some great music doing
mixtapes
in other people's beats and [ __ ] like
that and then that eventually primed him
up to where when his album came out
people knew who he was you know because
he had been putting out so many mixtapes
for free you know and really it's
realistically it's just the album that
you put out for free and you call it a
mixtape and depending how you make the
transitions from one song to the next as
well you know you sort of have to do all
that [ __ ] have somebody host it as
opposed to an album you know you're just
doing songs and you got transitions but
there's nobody talking in between
there's nobody - up the record as you go
along and mixtapes definitely do that
especially East Coast mixtapes but
realistically not not too many people
are I mean you don't hear about them as
much as you used to more people who are
just like more artists are doing songs
now just busting out songs and maybe EPS
and albums not not necessarily so many
mixtape full [ __ ] songs put it on
YouTube or some other Spotify right now
get a million - downloads and go on tour
yeah
and you saw 82,000 ticket sales
anyone put anything on iTunes now yeah
thank you put your music on iTunes now I
mean SoundCloud was where a lot of
people put their mixtapes when they put
them out and and albums and [ __ ] like
that that they're gonna give out for
free now I don't know if it's the same
get down but you know you could find a
lot Deron datpiff live mixtape live
mixtapes and uh and SoundCloud you know
what's another one uh some other [ __ ]
but like those are the three main ones
you would find all the good stuff at you
know but that's that's the get down
album is a different because it's all
[ __ ] that you would clear that you have
to clear you know in terms of publishing
and samples and all that stuff and then
you sell that and that's out in the
market for sale and you know if that's
like it goes under all the statistics
that happen you know where they track
the record what it did what it sold you
know what markets it's sold best in
whereas a mixtape you'll keep track of
all that you get it out as much as you
can to the people you give it to DJs you
you know sort of a similar process but
not as much resource on it because
you're just giving it away for promotion
whereas the mixtape is the promotion
piece before the album comes out to get
that the hype on the album you know
because that's where all the hits are
gonna be all the raw crazy songs are on
the [ __ ] mixtape and all the hits are
on the album that's usually the
mentality on how how people were doing
that that's [ __ ] brilliant
it's brilliant how the music industry
has changed in front of my eyes you know
I went from being a fan to becoming a
novice I don't know I'm not I want to
get a song I wanted to download oh my
well the Earth Day by Willy Cologne
yeah Jesus Christ I had to contact my
wife on the other room she was pressing
button for the plane two minutes you
know all eyes go to a record store
using the pressing buttons right Laden's
trying to get a telegram to Puerto Rico
to get the rights to [ __ ] him Lily calm
music get home so brother I appreciate
like I said you put me on and you coming
on and sharing your [ __ ] knowledge of
the art of anything because an artist
and art is an art it's just how you
translate it yourself
thank you very much brother thank you
for coming on the church man god bless
you Happy Thanksgiving
hallelujah stay black
[Music]
till that was great insight from be real
like I said I went down to the studios I
didn't know what to expect at first and
I talked to his dudes Ross dude the
black group with the camera was cool as
[ __ ] and we have gone down there and
done a show and I came back and I was
blown away and I went up to leak Joe's
podcast and I was blown away
and there's something I like to do
something in between that you know
something in between that sighs well
they both have huge buildings
ya know goes up but which is a little
bit more than we need but it looks like
a like somewhere where I would live if I
was still being there you know like I
would face if you're like a single guy
yeah single guy with a [ __ ] heat in
that mama god that'd be crazy that water
right there you know it gives it that
feel but to see God listen what keep it
from Hera
what has always kept me sharp which I'm
going back to do it's not hangin out to
calm me stall or a factory or The Improv
well I got ready for Gabriel spec I was
banned from The Comedy Store not bad I
had banned myself from going down that's
weird that I started going to these
places and I would watch these young
kids and they will inspire me and I put
together like this 20 minute heater set
in six months hanging out with these
young kids and closing the ha ha ha
every weekend I would sit there that
number I took in I introduce you to the
hooker she took it to that place tried
to suck it there for the small 42 kissed
your neck oh my god with the bandages
he's a boy to be literally escaped from
the hospital
so you know it's it's sometimes you're
moving yourself and reminding yourself
away you're from and scraping up that
no that's why I'm dying to go to that
place with you other fourth-wall yeah
yeah yeah we're it's it's exerting to me
I got the Shamu we have to leave we got
to leave with everybody we're gonna
leave here [ __ ] tomorrow to win the
amp I gotta to get there over one by six
could you say oh they put the nose oh
thank god the show wasn't tonight no you
know listen my niece is flying and
there's nothing worse than flying into
someplace and somebody says to you
listen I'm working and you have to take
a bus or a train or a cab in my world is
nothing worse than that you know I flew
all the way he and Alicia to do a show
up at the airport I walked a half a mile
but just show me to me meet me somewhere
so I'm not [ __ ] unleashed in hell so
I had made plans to go down to pick up
my niece tomorrow morning I was going to
leave the house at 5:30 you guys all my
[ __ ] animal I would hit I would smoke
a little dope have a protein shake and
then hit Denny's
you don't take me now is to get leave
any just the traffic closer to two lanes
you people won't believe this listen you
know you all have in cities and towns
and provinces whatever the [ __ ] you live
and every once in a while don't you
aren't you driving down the street and
you say to yourself I do not [ __ ]
believe this sign okay well if you drive
to the airport now
about a mom before you get to the
airport
it's like world construction starts in
the weekend over the 20th and then
January 4th well isn't that the busy
[ __ ] time of the year at the airport
so they shut it down
you leave sort yeah they and they've had
construction there for jeez in West
Chicago so instead of four lanes it cuts
down to two for about ten minutes how
many [ __ ] cars are gonna drop and
pick up people on [ __ ] Wednesday and
[ __ ] Thursday new people I believe
good idea and they're shutting it down
to two lanes
imagine they drive like animals so
they're saying from the [ __ ] century
road where you make the right right okay
so the top of the airport through the
intense security this time dogs two sets
of security Wow I found this out Sunday
because my buddy is a cop
and I talk to them when I go I got to
pick my niece up on Wednesday goes what
time I know that's not a good idea now I
talk called my uber buddy if he goes
listen she's still got a walk upstairs
to the back platform and stand there
like a savage and if I don't see her
it's gonna take me 45 minutes to get
around again this is I love my nieces I
don't want her out there she's coming
with a boy from the war I know he's a
mortar Dov is the first time he's ever
caught me even saying so what I'm doing
is a solicitor I told her where she was
landing I know exactly or that Airport
like the back of my hand she's carrying
our luggage they said just walk straight
hooker right can go sign your name and
get the next cabba I text her the
address
my wife texted he addressed and [ __ ]
I told her exactly what to say so the
dude wouldn't rip her off you follow me
and I will call me as soon as you get in
that [ __ ] cab
but I'll tell you what this aces concert
I don't get off yeah [ __ ] Westwood to
some salami sandwich and I don't need
that [ __ ] you're going to [ __ ] this
is where you're going
so I meet her at the house and then
we'll hang as a school I gotta go to
Mercy's 10 o'clock
karate presentation she ain't about yeah
she's gonna belt you breaking opposed
their [ __ ] head tomorrow for her hey
I hope so
there's like a little turkey dinner
there you got to do a potluck I got I'm
only gonna sit there for a [ __ ] hour
with him and after that I'll call you up
and we'll get the party started George
Perez Elena's down there we'll pick up
the Agostino on a mission from Satan and
just like we did every year the last two
years I think the first year I was too
high to drive but I was too embarrassed
to tell you but anyway I hope you
enjoyed this episode of the special fun
be real talking about art how you
balance and how you stay fresh because
this is what's been burning me the last
90 days people you know whatever you do
as an art is always great for my girl
Jennifer Jones it's when you turn it
into a business where you're like why
the [ __ ] do I do this sometimes because
people gonna break my balls anyway I
don't know I put 20 years and this is
what the [ __ ] it is I don't know what
the [ __ ] to tell you this could be crazy
but the last episode we were talking
with Ida about the Santeria that you do
and you you were talking with be real
about it like did do you think that he
came and talked about what's been
bugging you is something with that or or
is that reaching too much I don't know I
don't know yeah it was just something
that's on my mind a long time you know I
became a comic to be a comic but along
the way when I got here I kind of liked
that from time to time guys nothing
wrong with it together a set get some
fresh legs for a week's why you're
[ __ ] on the set you think the new
angles I gotta think up a new angles
people I've been hitting the same
[ __ ] drum for the same five years I
got it switch it around a little bit so
understand if I don't come to your town
next year let's see what happens with
Netflix and not me and Lee gonna put
something together to blow your [ __ ]
brain all right that I will let you down
[ __ ] never you know why I'm the
uncle [ __ ] Joey that's number one
number two it's Thanksgiving
it's our [ __ ] time right now you know
how lucky we are that we have each other
you know how lucky we are and we have
that stupid [ __ ] page I mean I love
the kid who's [ __ ] running it but we
have a bunch of Momo's on it but you
know how lucky we are we get to chitchat
about the vicodin proms and a pill prom
from the blow prop and the sex browns
and that you know I've always said I
wanted to do a podcast that you took
some homework I can just do a podcast
and sit here and mealy crack for these
and I can hire a writer and it's a
[ __ ] radio show this is not a radio
show this is a radio show from a little
misfit jhooth and [ __ ] Boston who
thinks never fit in but he does he's a
sweetheart of a guy and a fat [ __ ]
ex-con comedian with a weird sense but
let me tell you some nobody to get you
off that bed quicker than I can all
right so what I want to do is wish you
and your families a [ __ ] Happy
Thanksgiving especially the church the
inner circle of [ __ ] bobbies and the
[ __ ] bobby'll alingas and the Lord
and the you know a lost warrior and
[ __ ] your buddy
TJ stretchy oh and the guy who [ __ ]
sends me letters
your buddy Rico picot Petrocelli and
listen don't wings ya know the guy who
sends letters on Gmail Oh Dante does he
mean Dante ghazini listen we got a great
[ __ ] family this is a [ __ ] great
family
we had second chances in our lives when
we took advantage of them we're not the
[ __ ] king of what we do but we'll
hold alone so thank you for giving us
another year of your time you know I'm
saying number one I want to thank Allah
for always being with us from number
from day one and this is why I love them
there's now your Inanna customer you
know what time of the year is it's right
you ration your MCT oil which is [ __ ]
tremendous you've outgrown your happy
kettlebell and you're down to your last
alpha brain instant pack because you
know it's gonna hit you with a biggest
sale of the [ __ ] year
oh so this Friday November 24th on it
it's turning up the Black Friday sale
till 11:00 stock up 25% off supplements
including alpha brain 30% off apparel in
gear doorbuster deal
like 50% of the werewolf legend
kettlebell and even exclusive new
products like the NCP oils and vitamin D
sprays if you're already a fan on it
like I am you know me dawg
between the shroom Texas fruit export
and the [ __ ] nada chocolate had forth
protein that's what I live by it's a
time to stock up like a prepper for the
winter it's like stocking up with the
edibles now Lee's got a good idea but
have a thing if you're curious about
I'll check out what they have to offer
and just give something a try and it
doesn't mess around you will not be
disappointed it's a do me a favor head
tonic calm Black Friday and sign up for
alerts again that's on it calm Black
Friday to take advantage of the biggest
deals of the year that's on it
dot-com slash black friday go down the
column don't forget to always press in
church and tell them your uncle Joey
sent you number to listen everybody
needs some [ __ ] Jesus everybody's
looking to make a dollar the old [ __ ]
you kid who wants to show up on
Thanksgiving with bunny rabbits [ __ ]
pockets with a story you're not gonna
believe in I went out last night I got
pickpocketed know you're a [ __ ] Mook
that's what happens but you got a scale
you an idiot savant do you know how to
pick a game every week you're smart
you're not like the other suckers that
are picking 18 games you know how to get
a game and load up like a [ __ ]
you understand me because you can feel
in your bones that it's gonna come in
and even though you got eight dollars in
your pocket and whatever's in your piggy
bank Columbus took a chance so are you
you blessed that [ __ ] look for a
thousand [ __ ] dollars and there you
are then the Friday after Thanksgiving
getting your dick sucked and your balls
like I can make that happen you know why
my bookie dot AG listen you need it and
I know where you get it my book is the
place to score serious cash on your
scorch prediction so listen you're good
at what you're [ __ ] do you know and I
know believe it or not the
days are just around the corner and
that's biggie this big money ever made
was December selling sports information
why because you got the bowl games you
got college basketball
you got pro basketball you got a pro
football he's at Pocono football
playoffs listen it's like going to the
bank ATM machine every [ __ ] day and
that's what it's all about him while
this means plenty of parties gives
freaks spending you hang out with
[ __ ] you know it also means there's a
lot of football basketball hockey games
and like I said you can score big every
day man up and play like the pros on
game day you can play the money line
side or total my bookie is your hookup
for all your betting needs and offers
super-fast payouts when you win
Bam Bam boom where your bet is just as
important over your bet none and if you
want more money betting on games you
gotta go with my bookie thought AG
they're the only site I'd recommend I
trust them but you don't have to take my
word for check about yourself
they have odds on every matchup and a
mobile site that makes wagering on your
smartphone a breeze jack i'ma tell you
what uncle George would do for you out
of respect for the Indians and the
pilgrims join now and my bookie will
match a deposit went up to a 50% bonus I
gotta take Pacific I gotta take a sip of
water because I might faint from that
[ __ ] deal that's a great bonus again
join now and my bookie will match a
deposit with a 50% bonus use promo code
Church to activate the offer and get the
party started
freaks limos you know saying you'll be
calling Jack's girlfriend saying listen
to this chick snorting the line off my
Uranus visit my bookie AG use promo code
Church today you play you win you get
paid the other standing and that's the
name of the day it's getting paid you'll
be walking around like Mayweather
so go to my bookie dot AG promo code
Church number three you're a fat [ __ ]
you're thinking adjoining Jitsu you hit
me on the [ __ ] Church punch
Gmail site you're too embarrassed to hit
me on the church website you can say Joe
you're a fat [ __ ] why'd you get you
goose Fuji sports.com that's why I got
my geek first yeah I got from them I
borrowed it a friend of mine said try
this on I don't know what it was but it
felt like a glove
I went home order the size bigger the
super rod Oh super yacht or something
like that tremendous eye all at the
Seiko sei ko but the super ATO is my
[ __ ] favorite of all time I'm a big
guy people hang on my neck they tug they
pull tip top my Google Acosta loves
brand [ __ ] know what I'm gonna do for
you for Black Friday forget ten percent
I'm slashing it fifteen percent go to
Fuji Sports calm right now look at the
great apparel they got whether it's the
rash guards the new elemental G is
tremendous also it's white and blue the
blue on his bad ass and also look at
like that navy blue purple one it's like
99 bucks with the Fuji on the side oh
[ __ ]
you'll be looking at sharper you're next
Yugi to class and you're feeling good
it's light it's tougher than death go to
Fuji sports.com right now again I want
to thank my man Lisa at I want to thank
my man be real and I want to let you
guys know December 3rd
the Nova Theatre with my man we love
Walker December 4th San Diego the
observatory again I'm opening for
wheeler 20 bucks people and Tuesday the
5th I'm opening up four wheeler again at
the observatory in Santa Ana Lisa I will
be giving their all three nights signing
autographs and taking pictures of what
Happy Thanksgiving
I love your [ __ ] with all my
heart stay black stay healthy be careful
and have a great weekend love you